hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live atomkraft nein danke das haben ganz
viele ganz langen gefordert und
deutschland wollte auch aussteigen keine
atomkraftwerke auch keine kohle und
weniger gas und jetzt haben wir durch
den russischen krieg in der ukraine
festgestellt wie abhängig wir immer noch
von gas sind vor allem brauchen wir das
fürs heizen aber auch für strom und
deshalb wird über eine lösung aktuell
diskutiert die auch beinhaltet zurück
zur atom strom und kohle zumindest für
eine weile denn einige haben angst angst
vor einem so genannten black out
blackout was heißt das blackout das ist
ein stromausfall ein großer für uns alle
und deshalb die frage heute bei uns
droht der blackout ohne atomkraft
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit
christoph maurer
er arbeitet für die beraterfirma
concentric die sich intensiv mit dem
thema energieversorgung beschäftigt wir
sprechen gleich mit ihm und wie immer
klar gilt eure fragen kommentare könnt
ihr stellen in dieser sendung ich möchte
sie nämlich gerne weitergeben eure
fragen an unseren experten schreibt per
mail oder kommentiert direkt im stream
und was das bedeutet ein sogenannter
blackout und wie deutschland das
verhindern könnte schauen wir uns zuerst
in einem beitrag an von laura rosinus
blackout ein großflächiger stromausfall
experten befürchten dass das risiko
dafür steigt denn deutschland will raus
aus gefährliche atomkraft
klimaschädlicher kohle und russischen
gas und muss raus um energie ziele zu
erreichen hin zu mehr erneuerbare
energie sie aber liefern anders als
fossile brennstoffe nicht alle
unterbrechungsfreie strom denn es gibt
zeiten in denen keine sonne scheint und
kein wind weht das sind so genannte
dunkle flotten sie sind die größte
gefahr fürs stromnetz allein zwischen
2015 und 2020 gab es drei phasen in
denen die erneuerbaren weniger als 20
prozent ihrer leistung ablieferten in
solchen dunkel flauten könnte es also
schwierig werden mit der stromversorgung
hier spalten sich die meinungen ohne
konventionelle kraftwerke sei so eine
stromlücke derzeit nichts überbrücken
sagen experten
andere sagen dunkel flauten seien selten
und beherrschbar dazu bräuchte es ein
digitales smarties flexibles stromsystem
gibt es noch nicht
und dieses system müssen
dann haben wir immer zu jeder sekunde
eine versorgungssicherheit eine
möglichkeit strom speichern in
gewaltigen batterien zum beispiel oder
auch so genannten
pumpspeicherkraftwerken das geht so wie
hier im pumpspeicherkraftwerk hohen
warte 2 steht viel energie zur verfügung
denn wasser aus der saale hochgepumpt
gibt es zu wenig strom fließt das wasser
über turbinen wieder zurück und
produziert so strom allerdings
heute in deutschland eine
speicherkapazität von 40 gigawatt
stunden mit diesen 40 gwh könnte ich
deutschland je nachdem wie gerade die
stromabnahme ist zwischen 30 bis 60
minuten versorgen
die speicherkapazitäten für strom in
deutschland sind also enorm begrenzt und
die ziele für die energiewende ehrgeizig
wenn es keine konstant liefernden
energiequellen gibt wenn es an smarten
systemen und speichern fehlt ist der
blackout dann nur eine frage der zeit
eine große frage über die wir sprechen
können mit dem energieexperten mit
christoph maurer schön dass ihr heute
abend dabei sind
guten abend herr maurer wir haben gerade
im beitrag gehört ist das so ist der
blackout dann nur eine frage der zeit
was ist ihre einschätzung
nein das würde ich so nicht sagen man
muss sich vergegenwärtigen dass
technische systeme natürlich nicht 100
prozent zuverlässig sind so wie er in
der vergangenheit blackout hatten in
einem system in dem es noch ganz wenig
erneuerbare energien gab so können wir
auch für die zukunft nicht vollständig
ausschließen dass es einmal zu einem
blackout kommen wird aber wenn wir
energiewende richtig umsetzen und uns
über die verschiedenen herausforderungen
die dabei sicherlich entstehen
rechtzeitig gedanken machen und konzepte
entwickeln wie wir damit umgehen dann
würde ich nicht sagen dass einer
erneuerbaren energien sind basierendes
system unsicherer ist als eines das wir
in der vergangenheit hatten das heißt
wir können den blackout sehr wohl auch
in einem solchen system vermeiden und
wenn wir aber nochmal kurz bei diesem
begriff bleiben was das genau bedeutet
also wozu führen solche massiven
stromausfällen im schlimmsten falle
naja also ein blackout muss man dazu
sagen ist tatsächlich eine sehr
großflächige unterbrechung der
stromversorgung ja dann sind
hunderttausende millionen menschen ohne
strom das ist etwas was sehr selten
passiert die letzten wirklich großen
blackout ereignisse in europa hatten wir
2003 in italien und 2006 da gab es
europaweit eine vergleichsweise große
also viele kunden betreffende aber kurze
versorgungsunterbrechung das szenario
vor dem man tatsächlich angst hat ist
das eine sehr große region tatsächlich
ohne spannung ist und dann die
übertragungsnetzbetreiber das netz
tatsächlich erst wieder aufbauen müssen
nennt man das dann das ist nicht einfach
dass man einen schalter einschalten kann
und dann ist wieder strom da sondern man
muss dann sehr schrittweise das netz
wieder
bis man wieder einen stabilen
systembetrieb hat und das kann schon
sehr lange dauern einige stunden
typischerweise wenn alles gut läuft und
in einer solchen phase sind natürlich
sehr viele kritische kunden auch nicht
versorgt und da muss man sich dann
gedanken darüber machen wie überbrückt
man dass alle wirklich kritischen
verbraucher sind dazu gehalten auch
schon in der vergangenheit und sollten
das auch tun notstromversorgung
aufzubauen krankenhäuser zum beispiel
oder so um eine solche phase überbrücken
zu können weil 100 prozent ausschließen
können sie den blackout nicht aber
natürlich gilt je länger eine
versorgungsunterbrechung dauern würde
desto kritischer während ihrer folgen
deswegen ziehen die prozesse die wir
haben darauf ab dass man im normalfall
nach einigen stunden auch nach einem
großen blackout typischerweise wieder
strom haben sollte es gibt schon direkt
die ersten fragen und kommentare bei uns
im stream und die erste kommt von sin
form bei youtube möchte er wissen wie
viel anteil an unserem blackout
risikozone enters beziehungsweise
unserem strom strom problem hat er
verschleppte netzausbau ernennt da süd
link und co
naja also der
ich will nicht sagen verschleppte aber
hinter den plänen zurückbleibende
netzausbau erschwert dass das system
sicher zu betreiben es ist nicht
unbedingt so dass deswegen das blackout
risiko steigt weil wir prozesse haben
mit denen wir auch in einem netz das
nicht optimal ausgebaut ist dafür sorgen
dass die relevanten sicherheitsregeln
eingehalten werden dass wir also kein
unzulässiges sicherheitsrisiko eingehen
das führt eben leider dann dazu dass wir
zum beispiel nicht allen windstrom der
theoretisch produziert werden könnte
nutzen können weil wir immer wieder
windenergieanlagen ab regeln müssen
damit sie die netze nicht überlasten
insofern bremst der verschleppte
netzausbau etwas den fortgang der
energiewende er ist für sich genommen
aber nicht an ein zusätzliches
sicherheitsrisiko es würde einfach
einfacher werden sehr viel erneuerbare
energien zu nutzen ohne ein
sicherheitsrisiko einzugehen mit mehr
netzausbau insofern ist der netzausbau
wichtig und er ist für die ziele der
energiewende essentiell ohne dass wir
den netzausbau umsetzen werden wir nicht
unsere ziele erreichen aber zu sagen
wegen dem nicht so wie geplant
voranschreiten im netzausbau hätten wir
jetzt akut ein netz sicherheitsrisiko
das würde ich so nicht sehen bekommen
auch gleich noch mal ganz intensiv zum
thema erneuerbare energien und natürlich
auch wie unser strom sich im moment auf
teilt aber kurz den raum um das thema
abzuschließen das thema blackout auch
wenn wir schon gelernt haben der droht
jetzt nicht allerdings gibt es einige
menschen das haben unsere recherchen
auch gezeigt die er sich trotzdem so
große sorgen machen dass sie sich zum
beispiel mit notstromaggregaten
eindecken halten sie das für komplett
unnötig und übertrieben
ja das ist eine abwägung der schäden die
man hätte in einem fall eines blackouts
und mit dem mit den kosten einer solchen
notstromversorgung
es gibt kunden für die halte ich das für
essenziell ja ich habe eben
krankenhäuser zum beispiel angesprochen
und so weiter wenn wir kunden haben bei
denen tatsächlich katastrophale folgen
eintreten wenn die stromversorgung
unterbrochen würde dann sind die
gehalten eine notstromversorgung
aufzubauen haben das typischerweise auch
schon in der vergangenheit gemacht für
normale verbraucher würde ich
tatsächlich eher sagen dass dies im
regelfall keine lohnende investition
gut und jetzt haben wir es eben schon
angesprochen das thema erneuerbare
energien die natürlich auch eine große
rolle spielen auch schon natürlich in
den letzten jahrzehnten gespielt haben
für unseren energiemix den wir daher
haben und wären denn erneuerbare
energien tatsächlich die lösung dann
auch für eine energie sicherheit denn
auch da gibt es ja kritische stimmen
oder
naja wir müssen uns natürlich bewusst
machen dass wind und sonnenenergie die
wesentlichen pfeiler unserer
energieversorgung der zukunft sein
werden gleichzeitig sind die volatil die
haben schwankungen in der einspeisung
die auch nicht exakt prognostizierbar
sind und wir wissen dass wir phasen
haben werden auch längere phasen in
denen wind und sonne nicht zur verfügung
stehen deswegen müssen wir unser
energieversorgungssystem der zukunft so
auslegen dass eben auch solche phasen
überbrücken können eine wesentliche
technologie dazu sind speicher wobei
speichern weniger die in dem beitrag in
dem einspieler genannten
pumpspeicherkraftwerke und batterien aus
meiner sicht diejenigen sind mit denen
wir lange nicht verfügbarkeiten
erneuerbare energien über puppen können
sondern die technologie die da aus
heutiger sicht am vielversprechendsten
erscheint ist tatsächlich wasserstoff
wasserstoff den wir aus strom herstellen
können in phasen wo wir sehr viel
erneuerbare strom erzeugen haben mehr
vielleicht als wir ansonsten verbrauchen
könnten den wir dann speichern können
als gas gase sind gut speicherbar so wie
wir heute erdgasspeichern können können
wir auch wasserstoff speichern und zu
einem anderen späteren zeitpunkt können
wir dann diesem wasserstoff aus den
speichern entnehmen und in turbinen im
kraftwerken nur das sind eben dann keine
fossil befeuerten kraftwerke sondern mit
wasserstoff mit klimaneutralem
wasserstoff befeuerte kraftwerke wieder
zurück verstromen und daraus strom
produzieren wenn wir ihn benötigen das
funktioniert technisch es sind alle
leute sich einig dass das ein sinnvoller
weg ist die problematik dabei ist es
geht natürlich ein bisschen strom
verloren auf dem weg von erneuerbaren
strom zu wasserstoff wieder zurück zu
strom deswegen sollte man das nur dann
machen wenn es wirklich benötigt wird
wenn er keine anderen stromquellen zur
verfügung haben das ist keine
technologie für jeden tag aber um die
angesprochenen dunkel flaute zu
überbrücken scheint mir dass aus
heutiger sicht die technologie der wahl
zu sein sagen sie vielleicht noch mal
ganz kurz dunkel flottes wenn es nicht
jeder mitbekommen hat was bedeutet das
dunkel flaute ist der begriff der sich
in den letzten jahren eingebürgert hat
um eine phase längerer nicht
verfügbarkeit von erneuerbaren energien
also weder von wind noch von sonne zu
beschreiben man kann sich das zb in so
einer winter hochdruck situation ganz
gut vorstellen da ist es kalt und häufig
die sich deswegen scheint wenig sonne
die solarenergie anlagen produzieren
nicht gleichzeitig weil es eine
hochdruckwetterlage ist ist es
vergleichsweise ruhig in der luft das
heißt die windenergieanlagen produzieren
auch nicht und wir haben dann wenn so
eine phase stabil an liegt über mehrere
tage eben eine lange phase ohne viel
stromerzeugung aus dem volatilen
erneuerbaren energien und natürlich
müssen wir uns gedanken darüber machen
wie wir eine solche phase überbrücken
aber
technisch ist das möglich und die
konzepte werden auch erarbeitet das ist
nichts wo wir jetzt im blindflug darauf
zu steuern sie haben im wasserstoff als
einen teil der lösung angesprochen trotz
allem von unseren usern kommt vermehrt
auch das thema speicher trotz alledem
also strom speicherkapazitäten ich
möchte meine frage herausgreifen und
zwar fragt sich tobias kornmaier bei
youtube wie wird geplant die erneuerbare
energien großem maßstab
zwischenzuspeichern sowohl täglich wie
auch saison und ich würde gerne noch
anfügen gibt es da einen politischen
plan
es gibt pläne tatsächlich es gibt viele
szenarien die an dieser stelle gerechnet
werden an dieser stelle ich glaube man
muss tatsächlich unterscheiden zwischen
der kurzfristigen speicherung die wird
ganz wesentlich über batterien erfolgen
also indem wir zum beispiel dieses
einspeise spitze von solarenergie die
mittags entsteht in den abend in die
abendstunden in die nachtstunden
transferieren oder seiner täglichen
ausgleich der erneuerbare energien mit
der nachfrage zu bewerkstelligen und es
gibt eben diese saisonalen speicherung
die aus meiner sicht vor allem über
wasserstoff passieren wird gerade bei
wasserstoff sind wir dabei große pläne
und eine nationale strategie zu
entwickeln wie man das aus rollt zum
teil werden solche investitionen aber
schlichtweg auch über marktpreise
getriggert ja wenn die preise zwischen
abend- und mittagsstunden am strommarkt
deutlich unterschiedlich sind am mittag
wenn sehr viel pv energie zur verfügung
steht sie niedrige preise haben am abend
sehr hohe preise weil dann weniger pv
energie zur verfügung steht dann
entsteht daraus ein business case für
investoren die im zweifel speicher bauen
werden um genau an dieser preisdifferenz
zu profitieren und gleichzeitig dabei
dem system zu helfen indem sie eben den
ausgleich bewerkstelligen oder helfen
den ausgleich zu bewerkstelligen sie
haben gesagt es braucht eine nationale
strategie wenn wir jetzt aber mal im
großen im ganzen drauf blicken dann geht
es natürlich nicht nur um uns hier in
deutschland sondern wir alle hängen ja
zusammen in europa an einem stichwort
verbundnetz so habe ich bei der
recherche gelernt wie sehr beeinflusst
wird beeinflusst uns hier in deutschland
was im europäischen ausland passiert
also wie unsere nachbarn ausgestattet
sind in puncto stromspeicher und strom
mix also wie sehr hängt alles mit allem
zusammen
das hängt tatsächlich sehr stark mit
allem alles mit allem zusammen und das
ist tatsächlich ein thema in dem wir in
den nächsten jahren auch noch zu einer
vermehrten kooperation kommen müssen
tatsächlich macht es sehr viel sinn die
potenziale erneuerbarer energien über
das verbundnetz zu teilen wir haben zum
beispiel situationen in denen in
deutschland wenig erneuerbaren
einspeisung zur verfügung steht trotzdem
aber in unseren nachbarn ländern
gegebenenfalls sehr viel erneuerbaren
einspeisung zur verfügung steht wenn man
sich historische wetterdaten anschaut
findet man solche situationen immer
wieder und dann macht es eben sind
tatsächlich überschüsse zu exportieren
aus den nachbarländern nach deutschland
und andere situationen wird es dann
wieder geben in denen deutschland in
diese nachbarländer exportiert die
herausforderung dabei ist wir brauchen
transportkapazitäten um diesen ausgleich
zu bewerkstelligen das heißt wir müssen
die netze nicht nur national ausbauen
sondern wir werden auch international in
ganz großem maßstab netze ausbauen
müssen und wir können uns vorstellen
dass netzausbau schon im nationalen
maßstab durchaus nicht unproblematisch
ist das haben sie eben angesprochen
international ist das sicherlich auch
noch eine herausforderung ist sicherlich
ein thema das wir in den nächsten jahren
verstärkt angehen müssen und dann gibt
es eine frage die uns natürlich auch zu
einem wichtigen thema diese streams
bringt und zwar von neon 0 bei youtube
er fragt brauchen wir nicht auch
langfristig atomstrom um den stark
steigenden stromverbrauch zu sichern die
erneuerbaren energien benötigen viel
platz und lassen sich nicht beliebig
weit ausbauen was sagen sie dazu
ich bin der meinung wir brauchen
langfristig keinen atomstrom
es gibt länder in europa die das
durchaus anders sehen da müssen wir uns
bewusst sein ich bin da auch nicht
irgendwie ideologisch an dieser stelle
sondern würde sagen dass das tatsächlich
auch eine entscheidung ist die in den
einzelnen ländern getroffen werden muss
und eine abwägung aber aus der deutschen
perspektive halte ich atomkraftwerke
langfristig schlichtweg für zu teuer
atomenergie ist mir wahnsinnig teure
energieform wenn wir die neu errichten
wir sehen was die anlagen die aktuell in
frankreich oder in england errichtet
werden tatsächlich kosten und wenn man
das vergleicht mit den produktionskosten
von strom aus erneuerbaren energien dann
sind die einfach um grössenordnungen
teurer selbst wenn wir alles mit rechnen
bei den erneuerbaren energien was wir
brauchen ein speicherkapazität
wasserstoff produktionskapazität usw um
die volatile erneuerbaren einspeisung in
eine steuerbare in eine steuerbare
erzeugungsleistung umzuformen wenn ich
mal so will natürlich haben wir probleme
was die potenziale der erneuerbaren
energien angeht deutschland ist leider
nicht das land in europa mit den besten
potenzialen für erneuerbare energien ich
gehe auch davon aus dass wir langfristig
ein importeur von strom und wasserstoff
sein werden weil es andere länder in
europa gibt in denen man erneuerbaren
strom deutlich günstiger produzieren
kann als man das in deutschland machen
kann nichtsdestotrotz am ende sind
erneuerbare energien aus meiner sicht
die sinnvollste und kostengünstigste
option um ein dekarbonisierung das
energieversorgungssystem zu errichten
und ich sehe nicht dass wir aus
irgendwelchen gründen atomkraft
bräuchten
gerade es natürlich trotz aller dem
atomkraft in der diskussion denn um gas
zu sparen was wir ja im winter dringend
fürs heizen brauchen wird eben nach
lösungen gesucht wie wir wegkommen
können vom gas und eben auch darüber
wird in der politik nun heftig
diskutiert und wir wollen uns einen
beitrag davon anschauen darüber von
laura rosinus und danach darüber
sprechen
kürze duschen weniger heizen laufzeit
der atomkraftwerke verlängern wie kommen
wir weg vom russischen gas darüber
streitet momentan die politik die fdp
sieht in der atomkraft eine chance
gegenwärtig haben wir sichere laufende
kernkraftwerke wir müssen gas sparen das
dürfen wir nicht einsetzen für die
produktion von strom also ist es
sinnvoll und technisch möglich diese
anlage noch eine zeit länger zu
verwenden der grüne koalitionspartner
sieht das anders
das was das team oder will ist nichts
anderes als der wiedereinstieg in die
atomkraft und das wird es mit uns auf
jeden fall nicht geben und es ist so
dass die gaskraftwerke in deutschland
nur zu einem sehr kleinen teilen der
verstromung angesetzt werden und da nur
zu einem winzigen teil durch die
atomkraft ersetzt werden könnte wer mein
wärme problemen keine stromprobleme wie
viel gas brauchen wir also wirklich um
strom zu produzieren oder geht es sogar
ganz ohne wie der finanzminister sagt
und diskutiert wird eben über einen
sogenannten streck betrieb also dass man
die atomkraftwerke nur für eine gewisse
zeit nutzen würde würde das den reichen
würde es dabei bleiben was ist da ihre
einschätzung vermutung
ich glaube man muss da tatsächlich ein
bisschen sortieren erst also die frage
neubau von atomkraftwerken die wir eben
gesprochen haben ist zumindest eine die
man deutlich anders diskutieren kann
kopieren sollte als die frage der
weiternutzung der bestehenden kraftwerke
und selbst bei der weiternutzung der
bestehenden kraftwerke haben wir eine
unterscheidung zwischen zwei sehr
unterschiedlichen kategorien das eine
ist der sogenannte streck betrieb den
sie eben angesprochen haben da geht es
letztendlich darum die brennstäbe die
aktuell noch in den kraftwerken sind
etwas länger zu nutzen die kraftwerke
einige monate länger zu betreiben also
bis zum ende des kommenden winters zum
beispiel das ist eine maßnahme können
wir gleich darüber diskutieren die ich
aber grund 60 für nachvollziehbar und
sinnvoll halte einen längeren betrieb
der würde dann eine deutlich auf oder
eine aufrüstung der anlagen erfordern
eine erneute sicherheitstechnische
überprüfung eine sehr langfristige eine
neue beladung und müsste also neue
brennstäbe bestellen das dauert zwölf
bis 18 monate circa bis die verfügbar
wären vermutlich damit die kraftwerke
tatsächlich danach noch mehr eine oder
mehrere songs strom produzieren können
das ist ein punkt den ich aus meiner
sicht im moment für nicht notwendig und
nicht sinnvoll halte sowie das nicht
vollständig ausschließen aber das was
man sinnvoll im moment diskutieren kann
ist der streck betrieb wobei man sich
auch da vergegenwärtigen muss dass es
bei diesem streck betrieb eigentlich
weniger um das gas sparen geht es eben
im beitrag ja schon angesprochen worden
ja wir sparen mit einer mit einem
weiterbetrieb der atomkraftwerke etwas
gas es geht darum eine größenordnung
sagen wir mal von einem prozent des
jahresverbrauchs an gas in deutschland
das ist nicht nichts wir müssen
verschiedene kleine portionen auch
zusammenkratzen am ende insofern will
ich das gar nicht kleinreden aber wir
müssen uns einfach vergegenwärtigen dass
wir durchaus im kommenden winter auch
für das stromsystem selbst einige
risiken haben auch wenn ich den blackout
nicht für wahrscheinlich halte ja da
muss man einfach nochmal unterscheiden
es wird vermutlich keinen großen
blackout geben trotzdem gibt es einzelne
risiken in deutschland aber auch im
europäischen ausland zb die aktuell sehr
niedrige verfügbarkeit der französischen
atomkraftwerke für die man sich wappnen
sollte und als risikovorsorge maßnahme
halte ich tatsächlich einen begrenzten
strecke betrieb der bestehenden
deutschen atomkraftwerke die noch in
betrieb sind über den winter für eine
erwägenswerte maßnahme auch da gibt es
vor und nachteile und deswegen kann man
da nicht schwarz und weiß sagen das muss
passieren oder wird darf nicht passieren
sondern am ende ist das eine politische
abwägung die getroffen werden erst
zwischen kosten und nutzen persönlich
tendiere ich da aber dazu zu sagen
streck betrieb bis ende des winters wird
aus meiner sicht sinn machen wir haben
einige kommentare zu diesem thema von
unseren userinnen und usern im vorfeld
schon gehört in unserem community
teppich möchte ein paar davon vorlesen
und zwar schreibt kch müller absoluter
akw-gegner hier wir werden wohl nicht
drum herum kommen danke cdu spd und fdp
den wir diese situation zu verdanken
haben gibt aber auch andere stimmen die
schreiben zum beispiel gabriel die fans
auf jeden fall weiterlaufen lassen die
ganze welt setzt auf atomkraft nur wir
deutschen wissen ist wieder besser es
gibt so viele neue errungenschaften die
man nutzen könnte ganz klar dafür und um
noch jemand zu nennende planer schreibt
ich wäre fürs abschalten es muss jetzt
richtig unbequem werden sonst machen die
menschen niemals auf also heftige
diskussion auf jeden fall
unterschiedliche meinungen bei uns im
stream es gibt auch eine frage dazu die
ich ihnen gerne stellen würde und zwar
wo habe ich jetzt gelesen manchmal
rutschen mir die weg gerade hier zum
genau von big big pinsel dz bei youtube
er fragt sich wenn man die möglichen
folgen und die wahrscheinlichkeiten
eines super gaus eines deutschen
kernkraftwerkes mit denen eines
blackouts aufgrund von dunkel flotter
vergleicht welche bilanz ist besser das
klingt ja beides schrecklich
also ich glaube das problem ist dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines super gaus kaum
zu berechnen ist aber tatsächlich sind
gibt es keine hinweise darauf dass
deutsche kernkraftwerke besonders
unsicher wären an dieser stelle und vor
dem hintergrund glaube ich nicht dass
aus meiner persönlichen sicht dass ein
wahnsinnig großes sicherheitsrisiko wäre
dieser anlagen noch für drei monate
weiterlaufen zu lassen habe ich habe an
dieser stelle entschuldigung weil es
geplant doch einige die sich da ein
bisschen rum sorgen weil sie sagen es
sind alte kernkraftwerke da stehen wo
wir stehen wartungen aus die sind
eigentlich auch abschalten quasi
ausgerichtet es gibt zu wenig personal
im zweifel also es gibt ja schon einige
sorgen und ängste würden sie sagen also
für jetzt so ein strick betrieb muss man
sich aber keine sorgen machen
die anlagen werden sicherlich nicht am
31.12 plötzlich unsicher werden ich
glaube das kann man einfach mit gesundem
menschenverstand nachvollziehen am ende
bin ich aber kein reaktortechnik ja also
insofern gibt es tatsächlich da wiederum
fachleute die beurteilen müssen ob die
sicherheit dieser anlagen für einen
streik betrieb weiterhin gewährleistet
ist sie haben alle sicherlich
mitbekommen es gibt ja durchaus eine
eine lebhafte expertendiskussion in den
letzten tagen nach meiner wahrnehmung
ist die überwiegende meinung dass das
durchaus möglich wäre aber da will ich
nicht aus einer rolle heraus die die
keinen experte für reaktortechnik eben
ist das endgültig beurteilen wie gesagt
was mir sehr nachvollziehbar erscheint
und wichtig erscheint ist dass die frage
der sicherheit nicht voll am 31.12 von 1
auf null fallen kann sondern dass es
tatsächlich um einen graduellen übergang
zwangsläufig da geht haben sie sorge
wenn wir jetzt also uns natürlich auch
noch auf anderen baustellen
konzentrieren unseren strom
zusammenkratzen müssen im zweifel dass
der ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
dadurch ein bisschen ins hintertreffen
gerät und da sagen sie wahrscheinlich
jetzt erst recht wird die politik da
enorm investieren
wir haben jetzt gerade ein neues eeg
beschlossen die neue bundesregierung hat
ja das eeg als eine der ersten maßnahmen
reformiert dass tatsächlich eine
deutliche erhöhung der ambitionen den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
bedeutet muss sich zeigen
die dort angelegt wurden tatsächlich
alle greifen ja wir haben alle
mitbekommen in den letzten jahren ist es
zb beim windenergie ausbauen nicht so
schnell voran gegangen wie es voran
gehen müsste und die ziele die wir jetzt
haben sind sehr sehr ambitioniert wir
müssen deutlich schneller als ausbauen
als in der vergangenheit ob das alles so
gelingen wird oder nicht muss man sehen
aber ich glaube schon dass auf etwas
längere sicht durch die krise die wir
jetzt aktuell haben der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien er an fahrt
gewinnen wird kurzfristig haben wir für
den ganzen prozess der dekarbonisierung
des energieversorgungssystems leider ein
paar dämpfer jetzt zu verkraften wer
reaktivieren gerade alte kohlekraftwerke
das bedeutet wieder mehr emissionen zum
teil insofern leidet im moment die
energiewende ein bisschen aber auf lange
sicht muss das gar nicht nachteilig sein
der aktuelle prozess ich glaube den
leuten ist im zuge der letzten monate
und der diskussionen der letzten monate
sehr eindeutig klar geworden dass wir
unsere abhängigkeit von fossilen
energien reduzieren müssen und das kann
der energiewende eigentlich auf lange
sicht nur nutzen damit wir noch mal alle
genau im thema sind wo unser strom zu
welchen anteilen eigentlich genau
herkommt wieder aus was er sich speist
haben wir einen beitrag zur übersicht
vorbereitet auch wieder von meiner
kollegin laura rosinus
deutschland will unabhängig werden von
fossiler energie auf um vom russischen
gas los zu kommen muss der strom aus
anderen quellen kommen momentan sind in
unserem strommix 51 prozent ökostrom der
anteil davon steigt seit jahren
der großteil davon kommt aus windenergie
sie war 2021 etwa für die hälfte des
ökostroms verantwortlich der rest kam
aus sonne biomasse und wasserkraft
auch wenn der anteil der erneuerbaren
energien immer weiter angestiegen ist
noch immer kommt ein großer teil unseres
stroms aus kohle oder gas genauer gesagt
vergangenes jahr knapp ein drittel aus
kohle und 10% oscars 13 prozent zudem
aus kernkraft
gas soll in zukunft zunehmend ersetzt
werden zum beispiel vorübergehend durch
steinkohle aus diesem grund ging heute
das kohlekraftwerk währungen
niedersachsen wieder in betrieb ab
sofort bis april 2023 soll hier mit
stein wieder strom produziert werden
möglich macht das eine verordnung der
bundesregierung die besagt dass
steinkohlekraftwerke aus der sogenannten
netz reserve wieder in betrieb gehen
können um erdgas einzusparen
von unseren usern kommen hier wieder
viele interessante fragen rein so möchte
zum beispiel eher book wissen bei
youtube was sagen sie zu der aussage von
ulrike herrmann
wirtschaftskorrespondent in der taz dass
es nie genügend erneuerbare energien
geben wird um den bedarf in deutschland
zu decken
ja es gibt szenarien die das durchaus
zeigen dass es gelingen kann meine
persönliche meinung ist dass wir
tendenziell strom und wasserstoff auch
in zukunft importieren werden heute
importieren wir große mengen an erdöl
und erdgas er also der größte teil
unserer energie die wir heute in
deutschland verbrauchen importieren wir
produzieren wenn ich selbst insofern
werden wir tendenziell sehr viel weniger
importanteil in der zukunft haben als
wir das heute haben aber wir werden nach
meiner erwartung einfach weil es im
ausland günstigere potenziale gibt als
in deutschland möglicherweise strom und
wasserstoff in zukunft importieren ich
halte das aber auch für keine
dramatische entwicklung erwähnt
importieren viele andere güter und in
einer gerade in einem strom binnenmarkt
oder im europäischen binnenmarkt den wir
haben für energie macht es sehr viel
sinn zusammen zu arbeiten und zu handeln
und das kann eben dazu führen dass man
strom importiert bei wäre ich kein
großes problem dabei
natürlich wenn wir über handel und
importe sprechen alle wir alle stellen
ja fest also es wird alles immer teurer
auch der strom und engelbert klinger
schreibt auch mit blick auf die zukunft
hier bei youtube wasserstoff theoretisch
ok kostentechnisch arg teuer wie soll
das weitergehen wenn wir jetzt darauf
schauen also auf diesen aspekt strom
wird immer teurer in deutschland und
auch weltweit wie soll das dann für uns
alle weiter gehen
naja ich glaube nicht auf erneuerbare
energien umzusteigen würde
perspektivisch noch viel teurer werden
ich glaube wir müssen einfach das contra
faktische szenario wie man in der
fachsprache war mit berücksichtigen
einfach zu argumentieren es können immer
so weitergehen mit der nutzung von
kostengünstigen fossilen brennstoffen
ohne über die folgen zb für für
klimaerwärmung et cetera nachzudenken
und die daraus resultierende
schadenskosten ist eben keine
nachhaltige variante insofern bin ich
eigentlich davon überzeugt dass es die
günstigere variante ist langfristig wenn
wir auf erneuerbare energien umsteigen
und unser energiesystem dekarbonisierung
das trotzdem mindestens mal
mittelfristig der anteil der
energiekosten steigen wird da müssen wir
uns glaube ich keinen illusionen
hingeben das wird vermutlich so sein und
das macht es umso wichtiger an vielen
stellen darüber nachzudenken dieses
system so kostengünstig wie möglich zu
transformieren aber ja wir haben in der
vergangenheit letztendlich bestimmte
kosten die unser lebensstil verursacht
hat nicht tragen müssen wir haben sie
ausgeblendet und mit den folgen
beschäftigen wir uns heute das wird
keine nachhaltige lösung sein wir müssen
uns dieser herausforderung stellen ja
zum er ende jetzt auch dieser sendung
aber vielleicht das auch noch mal genau
aufteilen das geht natürlich zum einen
auf eine langfristige perspektive klar
aber es geht jetzt auch um eine
kurzfristige perspektive das schreibt
auch alles ist möglich bei youtube es
geht doch jetzt darum die situation in
den griff zu bekommen wir reden nicht
von in fünf jahren wir reden von fünf
bis sechs monaten wo eben der black out
drohen kann so schreibt er sehen sie das
aber genau so muss man es zusammen
denken dann doch das große ganze sollten
wir vielleicht einfach die langfristige
perspektive jetzt auch natürlich
mitdenken mal was da jetzt entscheiden
gilt ja eben vielleicht auch für die
zukunft oder sagen sie ja doch sind zwei
paar schuhe langfrist kurzfrist
strategie
wer ganz zwei paar schuhe sind es
sicherlich nicht aber trotzdem muss man
sagen eigentlich müssen wir jetzt
kurzfristig maßnahmen treffen mit denen
wir über den nächsten winter und
vielleicht noch den winter danach kommen
das sind sowohl technische maßnahmen als
auch durchaus wirtschaftliche maßnahmen
es wird sicherlich noch viel größerem
maße als bereits in der vergangenheit
geschlossen notwendig seien verbraucher
wenden um verbraucher zu entlasten von
den steigenden energiepreisen
die herausforderung dabei ist eine
wirksame entlastung hinzubekommen
gleichzeitig die anreize zum sparen
nicht aufzugeben wenn man schlichtweg
die preise für energie decken würde dann
würden auch die anreize zum
energiesparen was aber sehr wichtig ist
im moment wegfallen deswegen ist es gar
nicht so trivial eine eine sinnvolle
kompensation kompensations strategie
tatsächlich zu entwickeln wir müssen uns
aber gleichzeitig bewusst sein wir
dürfen unser langfristiges ziel nicht
aus den augen verlieren und wir müssen
nach dieser kurzen phase mit der wir
jetzt tatsächlich die aktuellen
herausforderungen bewältigen müssen dann
sehr schnell und sozusagen mit mehr
wersen noch einschwenken auf den pfad
zur klimaneutralität und den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien das ist das
langfristig sinnvolle kurzfristig müssen
wir eben mit ein paar brücken lösungen
wie der reaktivierung der
kohlekraftwerke und eventuell auch dem
akw streck betrieb auskommen aber ich
würde trotzdem gleichzeitig auch noch
mal vermitteln wollen aus meiner sicht
ist es nicht um also die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass jetzt im
nächsten winter ein blackout bevorsteht
ist nach wie vor sehr gering ja wir
bewältigen gerade die die verschiedenen
herausforderungen beschäftigen uns damit
wie wir damit umgehen aber es ist nicht
so dass die verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher damit rechnen sollten oder
rechnen müssten im nächsten winter würde
es zu einem flächendeckenden blackout
kommen sagt christoph maurer experte für
energieversorgung vielen dank dass sie
heute abend bei uns zu gast waren und
alle unsere fragen beantwortet haben
vielen
und wind das thema aber doch noch ein
bisschen interessiert und wer sich da
noch weiter für interessiert dem
empfehle ich ganz herzlich die ganze
doku blackout in deutschland
horrorszenario oder reale gefahr die
könnt ihr bei uns der mediathek schauen
und euch dann nochmal in allen details
informieren bis dahin erst mal vielen
dank dass er zugeschaut habt und für die
fragen bis zum nächsten mal tschüss